[Musique]
dessin ça fait depuis tout petit je
pense que ça a surtout commencé avec un
pic sous les browsers aides que j'avais
pris une fois et que je me suis dit ah
je vais dessiner ça du coup j'ai recopié
gelé redessiné je pense que c'est comme
ça que c'est parti
[Musique]
dans l'eau
le dessin si une partie ma vie c'est sur
papier en général si c'est juste quelque
chose de simple et que ça lui a tout de
suite
en général ça prend on va dire entre une
heure et deux heures sur ordinateur au
général ça prend beaucoup de temps mais
plus long c'était 17 heures les mangas
et les anus j'adore en décider j'ai mes
propres personnages et leur propre monde
la propre histoire et de temps en temps
je fais du réalisme et un peu de semi
réaliste possible
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je rêve va
de devenir mangaka pas mon gars c'est
celui qui crée les mangas il dessine il
peut être auteur compositeur
[Musique]
sur lui
je
on a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
choses qui me plaisent alors le visuel
ci vous tellement brûlés dans ce domaine
là et puis la clope est surtout réputé
pour ça donc forcément ça attire l'oeil
et dans l'équipe hop il ya aussi les
ambiance de camaraderie
l'ambiance chaleureuse c'est joyeux
c'est vrai que les idol souvent passent
des moments difficiles comme une tous
dans la vie mais ça veut pas dire qu'ils
peuvent pas et que nous ne disons pas
justement profiter la vie comme eux ils
le font donc j'aime beaucoup aussi
cet état d'esprit là
je
[Musique]